[Musique]
c
faire vivre le jazz et la culture malgré
tout pour sa 16e édition le festival de
maisons laffitte a dû se réinventer
les concerts seront diffusées sur
internet pas de public pas de live je ne
veux pas fonctionné dans le monde
il ya tellement de gens qui ont des vies
très très dur depuis qu'il ya ça je peut
que fonctionner dans dans le bonheur
d'avoir été invité et des et de pouvoir
faire ma musique est que ce qu'il
regarde on va pas entendre leurs
applaudissements
ça fait énormément de bien j'aime
vraiment ça ça m'avait beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup manqué bah déjà de
voir du monde
et puis je vois ensemble parce que c'est
c'est sympa de bosser tout seul mais
deux mois c'est long quand même sans
jouer avec des gens la programmation a
aussi dû être remanié frontières fermées
oblige les artistes sont principalement
issus de la scène française
sept groupes ont répondu à l'appel de
l'organisation et les retours étaient
tellement enthousiaste et généralement
de solidarité en auto serre que tout le
monde a eu envie immédiatement dès que
dès que j'ai proposé ça donc ça donc
c'est parti comme ça au départ ce soient
des partenaires institutionnels comme la
région ile-de-france où lula
la mairie de maisons laffitte où les
partenaires professionnels comme la
sacem l'adami le fcm ou bien des
partenaires privés des mécènes locaux
aussi ils ont répondu présent à l'appel
des enregistrements que le public pourra
savourer gratuitement du 12 au 21 juin
sur le site du festival et les réseaux
sociaux
le plus dur sera de ne pas vraiment les
applaudir
[Musique]